and the prince and prince harry and the
megan the duchess of sussex
are ending the year on a reflective note
with the debut of their spotify podcast
archwell audio in their first episode
harry and megan offer inspirational
messages for the new year
as we all know it's been a year and we
really want to honor the compassion and
kindness that has helped so many people
get through it
and at the same time to honor those who
have experienced uncertainty
and unthinkable loss i listened to it
this morning it's
so intimate it is it does feel intimate
so for the first time we also hear the
voice of archie their 19 month
old son who got some help from his
parents
you can speak in turn oh she's at fun
five fun
after me ready happy happy
new new year
so cute we're so used to seeing archie
as that baby but he's a toddler now
learning how to talk but this podcast
was incredible
it had everyone from elton john to tyler
perry to deepak chopra
all reflecting on the year and they
purposefully had people pre-record
their thoughts instead of doing a zoom
because prince harry said you know you
don't want to be telling people
you're on mute you know so they
purposefully did it this way and people
just
had so much growth to talk about um
tyler perry
said 2020 you know when you talk about
vision is when you see things clearly
and
he thinks a lot of the world finally saw
things clearly this year
good point did i hear an accent in
arcgis i think i did too he's like new
right i can't tell i don't know i mean
wouldn't that be fabulous
right i hope so best of both worlds